NET.
>> Dave: THIS IS THE 16th ROAD
THAT IS A GREAT PICKUP BY HIM
IT WAS 19:44, THAT IS HIS
LOWEST TIME WITH THE GOLDEN
KNIGHTS.
ELIAS LINDHOLM  RUSH,  THEN
SUMMARY CHANCES AND SO MANY
GOALS OFF THE RUSH AGAINST
ARIZONA.
THIS HAD A NICE LITTLE PLAY.
KICK
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT GOES TO
THE CORNER, BACKGROUND TO
SMITH.  REILLY SMITH.
THAT CATCHES THE TOP
SCORES! OPEN.
HE
CLOSER TO RETURNING.
WE STILL
LOOKING.
HE THOUGHT ABOU
THAT JUST CATCHES THE CROSS
BAR.
JACOB MARKSTROM ISIS FAN GETS I
MATTHEW TKACHUK, KNOCKED DOWN
BY McNABB.
THERE IS
UNDERNEATH WITH SPEED.
MANGIANPANE.
MIKAEL BACKLUND COMES AWAY WITH
DOWN BROADWAY.UP ICE.
WILL CARRIER IS TRY TO FIGHT
HIM OFF WITH THE PAST.
McNABB WALKS AN
KOLESAR, THE SHOT GOES WIDE.
HE TRIES TO THINK IT AND GET YE
MORE THAN OPHE
GOES UPSTAIRS.
HE GOES OFF THE STICK.
IT MAKES IT STEPHENSON, IT IS O
AND WE HAVE BACKHAND
GOING RIGHT PAST JACOB THERE.CO
INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE .
GREAT SHOT, TKACHUK KEEPS IT AL
FOR JOHNNY GAUDREAU